die lasche kurve hier hinter mir die
zeit seit monaten immer nur in eine
richtung es geht nach unten und immer
weiter nach unten geht die union mit
armin laschet unter darüber spreche ich
jetzt cdu vize und
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
[Musik]
ein herzliches willkommen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister hierbei bild
live im studio ich möchte diese änderung
beginnen mit einem moment einem foto aus
dem vergangenen jahr vielleicht erinnern
sie sich an diesem moment hier gemeinsam
mit armin laschet 25 februar ich hab's
nachgeschaut war das was war das
erinnern sie sich ich erinner den tag
sehr gut das war keinesfalls dienstag
warum er innerlich den so gut wir haben
die pressekonferenz gemacht aber da
steht und ich morgens um uns unser team
zu präsentieren mit dem wir auch
antreten wollten für uns sind ja dann
für den parteivorsitz er als
vorsitzender ich als stellvertretender
vorsitzender und ich bin danach nach
oben geflogen um einen
gesundheitsminister kollegen über die
situation in norditalien zu sprechen mit
abends zu hause angekommen anruf karl
josef laumann aus nordrhein westfalen
jens wir haben ein problem in heinsberg
dich deswegen einen echten tag so gut
das war sozusagen von der zukunft der
cdu bis hinein in die pandemie alles
gebündelt an einem tag das problem
heinsberg kam an dem tag aber ich würde
auch behaupten wenn sie damals nicht mit
laschet die unterstützung zugesichert
hätten ihn unterstützt hätten auf dem
weg zum cdu-parteivorsitz dann hätte die
union heute keine asche problem
nein ich muss nochmal zurück schon warum
ich mich dafür entschieden habe warum
wir uns dafür entschieden haben auch im
team anzutreten und die cdu hatte sehr
schwere wochen hinter sich im februar
2020 afd erfurt nun mal als stichwort
fiel auch an diskussionen wo gar nicht
mehr klar war steht der politische
gegner eigentlich innerhalb der partei
auch in der frage wie gestritten wurde
miteinander umgegangen wurde oder nicht
eigentlich eher außerhalb und wir waren
damals unter 25 prozent in den umfragen
und ich habe damals in dieser
pressekonferenz gesagt wir sind in der
schwersten krise der cdu und das ist der
grund warum wir gemeinsam antreten dass
wir heute ein toller wert 25 prozent und
trotzdem machen sie es doch heute ich
mal rechtfertigen sie sich dafür
mittlerweile dass sie ihn damals so
vehement unterstützt treibe warum ich es
gemacht habe oder was war es beiden sie
jetzt mit genau es klang er ist lang
gerade weniger recht fern sie haben mich
doch gefragt warum ich es gemacht habe
da habe ich ihn einfach noch mal
erläutert herr weil sie ja aber es klang
wie eine rechtfertigung deswegen wollte
ich wollte ich wissen ob sie das jahr
über sein ob ihnen das leid tut
mittlerweile ob sie das als fehler
empfinden dass sie damals ihre karte auf
armin laschet gesetzt haben es ist eine
stärke vor allem ja auch die union
zusammenzuhalten und ich sage noch
einmal das war eine schwere zeit und das
war eine zeit auch des umgangs
miteinander
die ist sehr wichtig hat sein lassen aus
meiner sicht dass wir einen vorsitzenden
haben der genau das gut kann menschen
zusammenführen unterschiedliche menschen
in unterschiedlichen positionen
zusammenführen der das im übrigen bis
heute jeden tag in nordrhein-westfalen
zeigt in seinem kabinett von karl xiv
laumann grad schon erwähnt unserem
arbeiterführer bis zur hendrik wüst
herbert reul tja auch in lage herr
starke personen eben in einem team
vereint und der übrigens dass wir die
auch mal sagen nordrhein westfalen ist
so vielfältig wie kein anderes
bundesland auch dieses bundesland
zusammen zu erhalten da rüttelt hier
auch keiner ahnen dass er nicht
ministerpräsident sein soll aber es wird
eben viele an seiner kanzlerkandidatur
schauen wir noch mal kurz rein wie sie
das damals am 25 februar begründet haben
neben armin laschet
ich werde dahin
ich werde daher nicht für den vorsitz
der cdu kandidieren stattdessen
unterstütze ich angelastet bei seiner
kandidatur für den parteivorsitz
armin laschet hat in nordrhein-westfalen
bewiesen dass er liberale
soziale und konservative in unserer
partei zusammenführen kann armin laschet
und echt zahlen dieselbe überzeugung die
cdu ist größer als jeder einzelne oder
jede einzelne von uns sicherheit und
zukunft dafür möchte ich mit armin
laschet an der spitze und dem duo stehen
und das ist unser angebot an die
verteilt gibt es dieses duo eigentlich
noch armin laschet jens spahn wir
arbeiten jeden tag gut zusammen ich bin
stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender
stellvertreter von armin laschet und
klar arbeiten wir mit auch allen anderen
in der führung der partei jeden tag
dieses tandem dieses tandem in dem jens
spahn das voller überzeugung armin
laschet unterstützt und stützt gibt es
das noch ich unterstütze aus voller
überzeugung unseren vorsitzenden
kanzlerkandidaten klar ich frag mich
deswegen war er armin laschet heißt es
stellt morgen noch mal so ein kleines
team vor so ein mini schattenkabinett
gehören sie nicht dazu
erst einmal ist jetzt die frage um
welche themen es morgen geht ich habe
übrigens sehr dafür geworben auch bei
armin laschet bei anderen
und da ist der vorsitzendes am ende
steht unser kandidat auch von überzeugt
dass wir jetzt natürlich auch eine
strategie und taktik änderung braucht es
wie im fußball wenn sie 2 0 vorne liegen
müssen sie anders fußball spielen als
wenn es eins zu eins steht so wir lagen
mal vorne jetzt steht es 2 2
wir sind unter druck durch die
gegnerische mannschaft um im bild zu
bleiben und deswegen müssen es
offenkundig der trainer nicht
funktioniert dann stellt man ihm noch
richtig starke co trainer sehen was
richtige und noch ein manager
das ist ein grund das ist berater das
ist eigentlich genau die stärke des
trainers die finde ich wir jetzt auch
gemeinsam in den nächsten vier wochen
ausarbeiten sollten und müssen nämlich
die stärke ein team zusammenstellen zu
können starke köpfe auch im kabinett im
engsten team haben zu können das können
bei weitem nicht alle kennen sie
irgendeinen anderen kopf bei der spd als
olaf scholz im moment ja die köpfe die
olaf scholz nicht unbedingt in seinem
team
eingeladen aber das ist doch eigentlich
für das geäst und kevin kühnert und bei
uns finde ich können wir ja auch wir
haben ja gute leute die genau union als
team auch außen ja mach ich hab laumann
und all in one genannt sind zum beispiel
die cdu wählt und die csu bekommt märz
und söder der bekommt auch noch sparen
und kramp karrenbauer der bekommt auch
linnemann und laumann und auch bär und
schön bei der digital wir haben gute
leute aber wir werden sehr wenige in das
team also es wäre jetzt ein richtiger
coup gewesen wenn armin laschet am
morgen sie präsentiert hätte und markus
söder präsentiert hätte und da hätte
plötzlich und friedrich merz vor allen
dingen und er hätte dieses team dann
seite an seite gestanden jetzt warten
sie doch erst einmal ab was morgen
passiert das ist schon ein markus söder
wird da nicht stehen wer weiß
stehen sie denn da ich bin morgen im
präsidium und bin was ich wissen immer
ein anderer haus ja schauen wir uns
nochmal diese laschet kurve an wie wir
es genannt haben da sind die
entscheidenden punkte markiert nämlich
schauen sie noch mal drauf ersparen sie
kennen aber die werte vermutlich auch
auswendig das hat angefangen eben mit
dem zeitpunkt kurz vor der ernennung
armin laschet als parteivorsitzender
stand dann die union bei 36 prozent in
den um fragen des runter und bei
ungefähr 28 prozent hat armin laschet
das ruder übernommen als unions
kanzlerkandidat heute stehen wir bei 21
prozent schauen sie sich das mit großer
geduld weiter an wie die kurve weiter
runter rauscht nein
müssen kämpfen den nächsten vier wochen
ist das was ich gesagt habe wir brauchen
einen strategiewechsel wir brauchen auch
eine ein wahlkampf der klarer macht die
unterschiede sie müssen anderen
wahlkampf führen als wenn sie deutlich
vorne liegen das ist einfach so da kann
man anders auch umgehen wir müssen die
themen stärker auch durchaus mal
prägnanter die unterschiede die einen
wollen steuern einführen und erhöhen wir
wollen steuern senken klimaschutz mit
verbote oder klimaschutz durch
innovation
multikulti leitkultur es gibt so viele
themen wo man auch die unterschiede
herausarbeiten kann und das ist aus
meiner sicht auch trinken oder sieht
sich besonders originell nach so langer
zeit wahlkampf so viel wahlkampf
erfahrungen die die union gesammelt hat
dann darauf zu kommen die unterschiede
deutlich zu machen jetzt läuft er soll
ja schon ihren weil warum ist es nicht
passiert bisher für mich ist viel
entscheidender in dieser phase wir sind
es nur alles aufarbeiten und werden wir
auch alles aufarbeiten aber jetzt geht
es erstmal darum in den nächsten vier
wochen stark und auch frau immer wieder
stärker zu werden ich möchte dass wir
dieses land weiter regieren dass wir
sind die 20er jahre führen und ich spüre
doch auch dass die große mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger nicht eine linke
politik will die wollen ja keine andere
politik alles nie irgendwo her
grundsätzlich vertrauten man ja schon
als eine grundsätzliche kurs der letzten
jahre der kurs der union der auch immer
die balance sucht zwischen sicherheit
und eben der notwendigen veränderungen
die zu gestalten ist gerade in den 20er
jahren wenn wir das ja sehen ist wird
viel an wandel anstehen wandel denen es
zu gestalten gilt die man aber auch
sicherheit geben muss und das ist das
was das union ausmacht und ich werde
jedenfalls die nächsten vier wochen und
das werden wir alle gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen 1 ist hätte stärker werden
wollen die ja nicht die wollen im moment
eindeutig nicht armin laschet er steht
in den beliebtheitswerten einen
katastrophalen stellen in unserem insa
politikerranking von 20 politikern auf
platz 17 hinter zb janine wissler von
den linken umso wichtiger ist es dass
wir alle gemeinsam auch immer wieder
deutlich machen was armin laschet ja
auch jeden tag zeigt in
nordrhein-westfalen und zwar sowohl in
der frage wer das land wird aber auch
bei den bei den themen ich mein ich bin
ja nordrhein-westfale ich weiß doch was
sich verändert hat seit 2000 17 das
fängt beim thema kleinkriminalität an
die einen die grünen stellenplans unter
atemschutz bei uns werden sie von der
polizei besucht und zwar tag und nacht
die frage wie infrastruktur beschleunigt
worden ist straßen gebaut werden die
gerade wichtig sind für die ländlichen
regionen überhaupt der ausgleich von
industrieland und klimaschutz wir haben
und vor allem armin laschet hat viel vor
zu zeigen und noch mal nach einem halben
jahr die armin laschet an der spitze
jetzt steht haben sie genau das alles
nicht deutlich machen können jetzt
kommen nur noch vier wochen die zeit
läuft ihm davon die briefwahl die läuft
schon wie sehr soll armin laschet diese
partei noch runter in den keller bringen
in den keller führen wir wollen sie
wieder hoch führen mit armin laschet und
darum geht's in den nächsten vier wochen
wir schauen uns einmal an wolfgang
schäuble hat er erhebliche mitschuld wie
man heute sagen können an der ernennung
an der nominierung von armin laschet zum
kanzlerkandidaten wir haben gestern
darum dazu gefragt ob ihm das
mittlerweile weh tut dass er sich ganz
offenbar geehrt hat
noch nichts wir haben entschieden ist in
die wahlkampf
wir beschäftigen uns mit dem wahlkampf
ich habe ja gesagt er ist der richtige
mann wir haben das richtige programm für
die zukunft soll stunts und dafür
kämpfen wir die vier wochen bist du
würdest
jetzt lasst uns einfach so laufen da in
der union klar wahlkampfes angesagt und
trotzdem kommt das alles so rüber als
sind das die letzten floskeln vor dem
sicheren untergang
herr weise es geht ja schon um mehr am
26 september ist geht herum ich 69 mal
wer dieses land in die 20er jahre führt
in 20er jahre die auch mehr an verändern
wo man umbruch mit sich bringen werden
als die letzten zwei jahrzehnte zusammen
wahrscheinlich das fängt in der
außenpolitik an afghanistan
transatlantisches verhältnis wie halten
wir die europäische union zusammen wie
wir wirtschaftlich stark bleiben vor 20
jahren war entwickler mercedes kaufen
die leute immer auf der welt das ist
nicht mehr klar die frage wie wir
gesundheit und pflege in zehn jahren
bezahlen entscheidet sich auch daran ob
wir noch ein paar produkte in die welt
verkaufen all das entscheidet sich in
den nächsten jahren und deutlich
herauszuarbeiten dass es nicht um bücher
geht um bilder geht um einzelne fotos
sondern darum wer dieses land mit
welchen ideen mit welchen impulsen für
dieses land in die 20er jahre führt das
schon auch die aufgabe von den herren
steht mittlerweile vor existenziellen
problemen 219 hat dieses youtube-video
für aufsehen gesorgt von rieso der die
union zerstören wollte das hat er
beileibe nicht geschafft nicht im ansatz
jetzt droht armin laschet das zu
übernehmen
muss eine frage und herstellung ist ohne
frage droht armin laschet das zu
übernehmen nein weil eine union die bei
21 prozent liegt das war weiß ich weiß
nicht wie sie wie sie das bei der bild
machen wenn es gerade schwierige zeiten
gibt
auflage sinkt wenn man sie dann
schließen sich zu hause im keller ein
unternehmen heraus ich kämpft dann mach
ich das dann wenn es gerade schwierig
wird und das ist das was wir jetzt
gemeinsam tun werden mit armin laschet
unserem kanzlerkandidaten mit dem thema
in der union kämpfen und um jede stimme
werben viele sagen mensch die lösung
liegt doch auf der hand man muss halt
einfach pferd wechseln und zack geht die
kurve wieder nach oben das schreiben uns
mittlerweile hunderte zuschauer unions
stammwähler und mit einem ersparen
wollen wir sprechen nämlich mit rainer
sobottka aus duisburg mit dem wir
zugeschaltet sind schönen guten abend
herr sobottka würden sie sich als ja
unionswähler als vielleicht sogar
stammwähler bezeichnet
guten abend herr sparen in guten abend
erweisen nach berlin also ja ich würde
mich als stammwähler auf bundesebene
bezeichnen ich bin jetzt 61 jahre alt
und habe meine ersten erfahrungen
1979 mit einer veranstaltung in herne
mit franz josef strauß gemacht und war
dann nach auch immer mit der cdu
verbunden bei allen wahlen die dort
stattfanden und ich werde in diesem jahr
wie so viele andere meiner bekannten
freunde oder auch andere bürger die man
auf der straße reden hat nicht mehr die
cdu wählen und der grund liegt einfach
darin dass wir mit der führungsperson
armin laschet nicht zurecht kommen und
ich spreche nicht nur für mich sondern
ich spreche wenn ich aktuelle umfragen
sehen für dreieinhalb bis vier millionen
wähler wie bisher die cdu wählen würden
aber erst jetzt nicht mehr machen weil
sie einfach mit der führungsperson von
armand laschet nicht übereinstimmen das
heim das ist auch nicht so dass herr
sobottka mit einem wechsel des pferdes
sage ich mal also wenn jetzt doch noch
markus söder zum zug käme dann wäre ihre
stimme wieder mit an bord für die union
definitiv nicht nur meine und wie
ersparen das eben mit dem verkäufer
sprach wenn ich etwas kaufe dann muss
ich vertrauen zu einem verkäufer haben
und anna schildt hat in den letzten
monaten obwohl er ein sehr guter
politiker ist aber für diese ganzen
herausforderungen die zur zeit anstehen
hat er nicht mehr das vertrauen in der
bevölkerung und aus dem grunde ist es so
dass da nicht nur strategie oder taktik
wechsel habe ich mir gerade
aufgeschrieben was sie sparen sagte
notwendig ist sondern einfach wie es
auch im sport möglich ist eine
auswechslung ersparnisse in die stimme
von herrn sobottka wurscht im gegenteil
ich werbe und pferde bis zum 26
september haben die stimme von herrn
sobotka werden
und um vertrauen werben und sie wird
nicht richtig verstanden sind sie aus
duisburg wenn wir beide
nordrhein-westfalen
sobotka ist ich denke sie spielen doch
auch und sehen auch in
nordrhein-westfalen
den unterschied den armin laschet
gemacht hat und macht seit 2017 wer
dieses große bundesland regiert er kennt
ja armin laschet als landesfarben
offenbar hat das bisher ihn nicht dazu
bewogen das kreuzchen abzusehen dort bei
der union zu machen bei dieser wahl
das ist richtig bis zu dem zeitpunkt
seitdem in den letzten zwei bis drei
jahren mit kubik 19 mit dem klimawandel
mit dem auftreten von herrn laschet
jetzt bei verschiedenen veranstaltungen
einfach sich herausstellt dass wer
lächelt im moment nicht mehr der
richtige mann am richtigen ort für diese
probleme da sind weil markus söder
einfach ein entschlossener mensch ist
der hat sich klar abgrenzt sehr klar
veränderungen möchte die auch
kommuniziert und das wünschen sich die
bürger zurzeit und aus dem urteil lasse
diese stimmen nicht mehr bekommen kann
nur plädieren ihn glücklich
auszuwechseln weil die politik entfernt
sich immer mehr von den bürgern und von
den menschen das in dreieinhalb ist
nämlich und stammwähler sagen 'bitte
wechsel dann tut es doch eher sobottka
sie besteht doch eigentlich dagegen dass
in der stimme sondern spiegelt wider was
wir einen zuschriften bekommen
selbstverständlich gibt es auch laschet
fans doch in der union das ist ja völlig
klar und trotzdem ist das natürlich ein
trend ein meinungstrends den herr
sobottka das schildern was spricht
eigentlich aktuell dagegen das pferd
noch mal zu wechseln
wie sie schon festgestellt haben wir
sind in diesem wahlkampf und wir haben
uns gemeinsam entschieden mit armin
laschet anzutreten als unserem
kanzlerkandidaten aus guten gründen die
ich gerade genannt habe gründe die wir
offenkundig noch viel besser werden in
den nächsten wahl so weil man es mal
entschieden hat zieht man das jetzt
durch das ist der entscheidende grund
daran festzuhalten der im laufenden
spielen wechseln sie nicht den trainer
aus doch wenn der sieg halt vor der nase
habe ich noch nie im laufenden spiel
ausgewechselt gesehen aber das mag an
meinen überblick über fußballspiele
legen sie an flächen besseren ich glaube
nicht dass das insgesamt die moral den
zusammenhalt erhöht und vor allem eben
auch in der sache in der person
ist doch jetzt darum geht dass wir
wirklich weg konsumenten und den letzten
wochen beschäftigt mit vielen dingen und
ja ich glaube niemand ist über dieses
foto über das viel diskutiert wird
unglücklicher als armin laschet selbst
das hat er ja auch schon gesagt aber ist
das jetzt wirklich der punkt um den es
geht am 26 september und ich finde wir
müssen halt stärker wirklich über die
themen reden und auch zeigen dass wir im
team mit einem in der stadt unterstütze
ich sage noch einmal mehr union
weltkrieg märz söder lindemann laumann
sparenberg viele andere die müssen aus
berka drauf wo legen sie aktuell herr
sparen wo legen sie aktuell die hürde
für die cdu/csu also was ist ein wert wo
sie sagen würden also das dürfe auf
keinen fall unterschreiten ich halte gar
nichts davon immer diese werte
darzulegen der wert wie er jetzt ist es
alles andere als befriedigend das ist
ein wert mit dem ich mich auch nicht
zufriedengeben will ich will auch gar
nicht darüber reden was noch ich würde
die andere richtung wissen sie wenn ich
im land auch unterwegs ein wie man das
gerade von den 80 90 wahlkampftermin die
ich mache etwa die hälfte
hinter mir und vielen diskussionen es
ist ja nicht so dass die ich habe 1998
wahlkampf gemacht mein erster das war
eine nach 16 jahren ist gemäss bag
stimmung die wir sehr eindeutig die ist
das ist keine es müssen jetzt andere her
stimmung die allermeisten bürgerinnen
und bürger wollen keinen grundsätzlich
anderen kurs und sie können auch im
urlaub gerne der tradition können auch
gut damit umgehen wenn die union
weiterhin die stärkste kraft ist aber
wir haben offensichtlich bis hierhin
noch nicht die brücke gebaut diesen weg
dann mit uns zu gehen was die themen
angehen weil olaf scholz als ihr erbe im
moment sich zumindest inszeniert und da
sage ich eigentlich ja auch zu dem was
sie gerade sie sagen das ist jetzt aber
keine keine rocket science zu sehen dass
man die auseinandersetzung so und muster
stimmt ist kein rocket science ist aber
bis jetzt aus meiner sicht noch nicht
ausreichend geschehen auch die
auseinandersetzung mit olaf scholz zu
suchen und vor allem wie er ist er ist
das feigenblatt einer linken spd ich
meine das programm ist so 1970 bis 1970
er nicht sein kann
am ende steuern erhöhen berlin dieses
berlin-mitte aber nicht die mitte der
gesellschaft was da im programm steht
und das auch deutlich herauszuarbeiten
und im zweifel auch mal zu fragen wir
sind eigentlich die leute mit denen der
dieses land regieren will das finde ich
schon dass man und mit wem überhaupt
nicht wenn wir sind sehr sehr klar
linkspartei und afd die vereinfacher die
populisten von links und rechts kommen
für uns nicht in frage so eine klare
aussage hätte ich auch gerne von olaf
also das ist jetzt also entscheiden denn
wenn herr weil wenn sie sagen er will
erbe von merkel werden dann muss er in
der frage wie er ist mit der linkspartei
herrschen wir haben es ja versucht
vielleicht haben sie es gesehen
vergangen waren zehn minuten gedauert
bis es dann immer noch nicht gelöst war
das heißt er hat an der stelle um das
wollen sie nach vorne stellen ist er
aber nicht der erbe der kanzlerin wird
der linkspartei nicht klar ist ist nicht
der erbe einer bürgerlichen regierung
ziemlich klar lassen sie uns
abschließend herr sparen über ihr fach
thema noch einmal sprechen über
natürlich die korona krise jetzt drohte
uns 3g in zügen und bahnen also nur noch
bahn fahren wenn man geimpft getestet
oder gewesen ist ist offenbar abgeräumt
und dass es ihnen zu verdanken
es gibt eine prüfbitte gab sie haben
geprüft vor allem das
verkehrsministerium federführend
offenkundig ja auch für bahnfahrten und
da gibt es im drei themen hat es eine
rechtsgrundlage sozusagen die rechtliche
betrachtungsweise ist es praktikabel es
überhaupt umsetzbar da muss ich sehen
wir haben anderes system als als
frankreich also in frankreich werden sie
kommen sie gar nicht in den bahnhof rein
zumindest wenn schnellzügen wenn sie
nicht schon dinge vorweisen und darlegen
bei uns sind bahnhöfe einfach
öffentlicher raum und ganz anders
zugänglich also dann im kanzleramt
wissen gehört habe und nicht wissen
können es ist praktikabel und die dritte
frage ist ist es infektiologie in dieser
pandemie jetzt auch unbedingt
erforderlich dann in der in der abwägung
und da haben wir einfach noch mal
geschaut wie sind die erfahrungen was
ausbruchsgeschehen angeht und
zusammengefasst kommen wir eben aus den
fachressorts die sich mit diesen drei
fragen beschäftigt haben zu dem von ihm
beschriebenen ergebnisse abgeräumt das
ding ist 3g in zügen kommt nicht ich
sehe ist nicht kommen jetzt stehen wir
also nicht heißt dass wir nicht trotzdem
aufeinander aufpassen sollten in den
zügen das ist ja klar
ist das auch auch einfach möglich weil
schutzmasken richtig sind das macht die
schutzmasken in den zügen umso wichtiger
es gibt ja einige die man überall die
masken fallen lassen sie nicht nicht in
dem bereich wo ich möchte jetzt muss man
sich entscheiden hat er schon ist man
auch in gesprächen hatte hier mal ein
mal im juni glaube ich oder ende mai
gesagt naja wenn jeder die möglichkeit
hatte sich impfen zu lassen das haben ja
längst hat die bundesregierung
festgestellt dann kann auch das kommt
auch der moment was sich aber verändert
hat zum beispiel ist dieser starke
anteil delta und das was wir auch
anschließend gesehen haben wie viel
ansteckender diese variante ist und die
zahl der ungeimpften ist verbunden mit
delta einfach noch so groß dass eine
tatsächliche starke belastung des
gesundheitswesens sehr wahrscheinlich
ist wie haben die pandemie der
ungeimpften jeder der nicht geimpft ist
wenn die zahlen jetzt weiter steigen
wird sich mit nahezu hundertprozentiger
sicherheit ohne schutz in herbst und
winter dann anstecken und das ist schon
noch eine andere lage als wir sie noch
vom halben jahr hatten mit einer anderen
variante jetzt steigen die zahlen
tatsächlich weiter wir werden womöglich
im laufe dieser woche diese magische 100
wieder erreichen beim incidents wert auf
denen wir ja nicht mehr so genau schauen
wollen oder nicht mehr nur
ausschließlich auf diesen wert was
passiert eigentlich wenn wir im laufe
dieser woche diesen wert erreichen von
der 100 dann ist das erst mal für sich
genommen auch keine gute entwicklung
weil es einfach zeigt dass dieses virus
sich immer weiter immer schneller
ausbreite
es passiert erstmal wegen der 100 für
sich genommen gar nichts außer dass ich
einfach nur die bürgerinnen und bürger
bitte miteinander zu sehen virus ist
sehr unterwegs aufeinander aufpassen wo
es geht im alltag aber wir haben ja im
miteinander vor allem ein hauptkriterium
seit beginn der pandemie übrigens unser
haupt grund auch warum wir die maßnahmen
ergriffen haben wie wir sie ergriffen
haben war ja die
funktionsfähigkeit des gesundheitswesens
dass wir patientinnen und patienten auch
tatsächlich klar derzeit behandeln
können und das ist jetzt eben ein stück
ist es nicht völlig losgelöst natürlich
wenn die zahlen immer weiter steigen
wird auch voller in den kliniken aber es
ist jetzt weiter entkoppelt als es vor
dem impfen war jahrhundert passiert
erstmal nichts mehr was es dann die neue
grenze also für sie zumindest im kopf
die notbremse wir haben ja einen
vorschlag gemacht wurde
infektionsschutzgesetz dass wir jetzt
die sogenannte hospitalisierung residenz
nehmen heißt also wie fico will 19
patienten wurden in den letzten sieben
tagen neu aufgenommen in den kliniken
und das macht schon sinn dass auch
regional unterschiedlich zu betrachten
weil natürlich die versorgungsdichte die
versorgungssituation auch regional
unterschiedlich ist wenn sie mich fragen
was ist denn so ein wert der zumindest
mal eine idee davon gibt die sehr starke
belastung die wir gesehen haben im
dezember januar in der zweiten dritten
welle war zum beispiel mit die stärkste
belastung 15 kurven 19 patienten neu
aufgenommen in den letzten sieben tagen
pro 100000 einwohner hat das war eine
situation regional da ist das
gesundheitswesen schon sehr
unter unter starker belastung ans limit
angekommen und das ist eine
größenordnung die ich jedenfalls nicht
wieder erreichen will wir danken für das
gespräch
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen und
cdu vize armin laschet will
bundeskanzler und sicher würden sie
darauf wetten ich wette nicht nur ich
kenne sogar dafür
herzlichen dank an jens sparen und wir
haben heute den abend an dem die drei
kanzlerkandidaten direkt aufeinander
prallen bei unseren kollegen von rtl
nämlich annalena baerbock olaf scholz
und armin laschet und wie das gelaufen
ist was die highlights waren das
analysieren wir gleich mit unseren
reportern und einer tollen gästerunde
hier
[Musik]